thank you good morning welcome to this
informal virtual baby district council
planning meeting
the decision to hold an informal meeting
has been taken as a result of the
current risks relating to the covert 19
pandemic
as this meeting is now an informal
meeting the committee members will not
be able to make decisions and therefore
there will be no voting on any of the
items on the agenda
members are asked to discuss the items
on the agenda and to confirm a steer to
the chief planning officer for each item
at the conclusion of each item i will
ask the chief planning officer to
indicate whether he is minded to accept
this recommendation made in the office
of report or to take any other action
having listened to the discussions
i will now ask the government officer to
read out domestic arrangements claire
mr chairman i want to read
i wanted to ask the point of order
okay at this point
why are we doing an informal meeting
and why could we have not met in the
council chamber there is no instructions
from government that we have to um
work from home to do these meetings in
fact i think the ruling is that we
attend endeavour house and take them in
in public
so why isn't this happening
i think that's a matter you may have to
take up with chief executive at the
moment
that's the ruling he's made
right and and and so we're
trying to get it to work peter on um at
this at this stage
um let's try and keep the thing
continuing that i i i accept what you're
saying mr chairman i accept i understand
that uh you're restricted by what you
have to accept and follow i wish to have
it recorded i strongly object to an
informal meeting when there doesn't seem
to me to be any reason why that should
be happening
and no one can explain it okay thank you
thank you
claire would you like to continue
yes thank you chair
please ensure that my
phones are turned off when not in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please remember to use the chat function
only to indicate that you wish to speak
and not to post comments or questions
please note that messages in the chat
panel can be viewed by people watching
the live broadcast
i'd like to remind everyone present that
this informal meeting will be called us
live to the internet and will be capable
of repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
because to have consented to being
filmed by entering this meeting as a
speaker you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council under the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
employees are not lawfully excluded
thank you chair
thank you claire
introductions today we have chief
planning officer
phillisbull
we have the area planning manager
mark russell
we have the case officers alex scott and
linda bacon
and claire philpot you've already met is
the
governance officer can i move to the
agenda please
thank you
i will now ask the government officer to
carry out a role call for the members
present
claire
thank you chair members if you could
just indicate your presence once i call
your name
uh councillor sue ayers
good morning i'm here
thank you councillor beer
present and kill
councillor busby
thank you carol hinton
here
councillor jameson
yeah
councilman mccrorl present
councillor mclaren president
councillor parker
present
councillor osborne
good morning i'm present thank you
thank you councillor owen
good morning
and councillor plum
yes i'm still here
thank you chair thank you to receive
declarations pecuniary and nonperkining
just by members for for for information
are there any to declare
nope
to receive notification petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme
we heard anything clear nominee
non-received chair
have we have a request for site
inspection
no chair okay okay
right
moving on to schedule reports to be
discussed
land to the east of hadley road elmsit
i will invite alex scott to introduce
the application
please alex over to you
well thank you chairman um i can just
try and uh
present my powerpoint presentation
there you go
hopefully everybody can see that
yes so um yeah this uh item on the
agenda is uh
application reference dc 2103561
and that's land east of hadley road
elmset
and the application before us is
an application for approval of reserve
matters relating to 41 dwellings
and this follows outline planning
permission
reference
b
forward slash 17 forward slash 0 one
zero zero nine
which was granted
subject to conditions in june of uh
2018.
now the current application is in
relation to matters of scale and
appearance of buildings only
as matters relating to access layout and
landscaping have already been considered
and approved by way of the outline
planning permission
and so moving to the presentation now
the first slide is a aerial view of
elmsett and the surrounding area all the
way down to
oldham
and the second slide is a closer
aerial view of the site outlined in in
red
this is a constraints map showing the
planning constraints affecting the site
and in summary
uh key constraints to consider i believe
uh the site is outside the built-up area
boundary of the village which is
outlined in orange here
there are two public footpaths
one internal to the site adjacent to the
north boundary here
and one external to the site running
adjacent to
the south of the site
the site comprises uh grade three
moderate quality agricultural land
now the nearest listed building
highlighted in orange here at utree
cottage
is approximately 140 meters
to the north of the site
and there is also a
special landscape area here in excess of
300 meters to the east of the site
now the nearest uh
flood zone uh that's environment agency
flood zones two or three
um is actually off the map and it's a uh
significant distance to the other side
of uh
elmsett park wood and spinney hill
to the to the east of the site if
everybody is familiar with that
this is the site location plan
submitted by the applicant
again outlander's site in red and the
built-up area boundary in orange
and this is the uh proposed layout now
um
this is exactly the same as what was
considered and approved at outline stage
um
i said at the top of
my presentation
matters for discussion today relate only
to the scale and appearance of buildings
excuse me
matters relating to layout access and
landscaping have already been considered
and approved
now the layout includes 14 affordable
dwellings and i'll
get onto the precise locations of those
in a bit
one hectare of public open space is
proposed split into four areas one
two three and
four uh there is also a centrally
located um
locally equipped area for play or leap
in this location
uh the net density
of the site is
27.3 dwellings per hectare
and back-to-back distances
across the site are no less than 18
meters as proposed
and just some
uh close-ups of the
various areas of the site
for you there
now on to the
elevations of dwellings these are some
of the market dwellings here
and
in total we have
five two-bedroom
bungalows
which are here
two two-bedroom semi-detached dwellings
six three-bedroom semi-detached
dwellings
six three-bedroom terraced dwellings and
eight four-bedroom detached uh dwellings
uh market dwelling-wise
and we have the garages and association
uh provided there for scale as well
turning to affordable dwellings uh the
locations of these are outlined in uh in
pink here
across the site across the frontage of
the site
and here are the
elevations of the affordable dwellings
proposed
now we have
one
two-bedroom bungalow affordable proposed
eight bedroom
no sorry eight two bedroom semi detached
dwellings
three three bedroom
terrace dwellings
and three sorry two
three bedroom semi-detached weldings
hopefully that's clear so just running
through that just to be clear one two
bedroom bungalow eight two bedrooms
seven detached dwellings three three
bedroom terrace dwellings and two three
bedroom
semi detached dwellings
and this is a street scene provided by
the applicant and this is the principal
street scene you would see
fronting uh fronting hadley road
to some photographs for you
this first photograph is the uh
the existing uh site frontage uh
fronting hadley road showing the
existing uh
footbridge leading to the public
right-of-way which uh
goes through the uh through the site
adjacent to the north boundary which is
proposed to be uh
uh replaced and that has been secured by
way of condition of the outline planning
commission
this is a photograph uh internal
of the site uh looking uh
looking south east across the existing
field from the footbridge
and then one um
from the public footpath which is
approximately here looking back towards
the existing dwellings front fronting
hadley road
and the rear of uh the nearest dwelling
at
garage road which is the neighboring
estate to the north
this photograph was taken uh just across
the junction of
soyuz
and looking back to the site which is
approximately this location just showing
the existing uh
public footpath infrastructure there
this photograph is from the far south
west corner of the site and we can
get an idea of the existing street scene
and this is the public right-of-way
mentioned before which runs adjacent to
the south
boundary of the site
outside the site but adjacent to
it and uh this final slide is a view
back across the site uh from the uh
southwest corner
um
across the field and you'd be able to
see the uh the rear of existing
dwellings renting the garage road estate
so that concludes the presentation
chairman and
if i may
refer to the area planning manager
perhaps for the recommendation to
explain the recommendation thank you
thank you alex yes chair um
the issue is that the this is all we're
looking at today is
is the scale and the design of the
houses because the layout and everything
was already agreed outline
um one issue to make you aware of is
that the applicant still needs to
discharge the floods related conditions
which they haven't done
hence the recommendation that we be um
that the chief planning officer
um
waits until those matters have been um
cleared before we issue the reserve
matters permission
thank you mark
thank you
moving on any questions for the planning
officer
i see your hand handy's up
counselor james
uh thank you chair
um just a couple of things um i wonder
if the planning of officer could advise
now i understand there's
lighting being installed on the
development and just wanted to clarify
is that necessary i mean there's no
other or very little lighting in them
set
and the street lighting would sort of
make this more a bit more of an urban
feel i believe i wondered if there's
any necessity for the street light in
that's one thing
and the other thing which
hopefully they can help with um
the houses five and six hadley road
voice parked outside their premises
because i've got nowhere to park
i've spoken to the agent
about this and he said they're minded to
do what they can to help it's bringing
up a planning committee
i don't think they're here are they
that wasn't anything planning officer
can advise
on
in that area
thanks
okay uh thank you uh counselor jameson
um yes the first point with regards uh
lighting um there is a condition on the
outline planning permission uh prior to
occupation we would need a lighting
design scheme
so that is
required prior to occupation i don't
believe we have details of that as yet
but that would be forthcoming
and
in terms of the parking um
well i'd i mean i would have to say um
that has already been uh considered and
and approved as as have
offsite highways works as part of the
the outline
and um and secured by where the section
106. um i don't know if the area
planning manager has anything to add to
that
mark
no what you say is correct alex we are
literally this application we're
literally looking at the scale and the
design alex and chair just that
okay yeah i understand that it's just
as i say the agent said they were happy
to help the residents and just to bring
up a planning committee but obviously
they've not set up so
and they would look to do what they can
i wonder if there's anything we can do
to
in that respect sort of speaking to the
agent further
and we
with regard to the condition for
lighting that's to do with ecology isn't
it i believe rather than
actual street lighting
uh this is gone alex sorry condition on
the outline
yeah condition of the outline condition
25 of the outline um i believe and so
what that says is prior to occupation a
lighting design scheme for biodiversity
shall be submitted to and approved in
writing by the local planning authority
um
yeah and uh yeah it is geared towards um
biodiversity but um
yeah that there are there are benefits
in terms of um
uh
other amenities i would suggest along
with that as well
okay
mr isabel would you like to last comment
i see you have your hand up
thank you chairman yes so so the
question of five and six in the parking
alex could you get the layout plan up
for us just to have sight of that
um and i believe as you were saying this
is not a reserve matter for layout and
parking
um associated with properties is
what you would expect to see on the
the outline scheme
but
it does strike me that the opportunities
if they exist
might be something for officers to take
away to see whether there's a
non-material amendment that might be
agreed to accommodate that i think
that's a question
probably not for determining this
application but if members were
uh keen that officers explore that with
the applicant and see whether there is
anything possible
we have the application before us today
uh it it might not be possible to
accommodate something
and certainly
the question of ownership title
occupation becomes a bit of an
interesting question but
if there is something to be looked at it
might be possible to accommodate it as a
non-material amendment but probably not
in relation to this application so um
alex could you just identify where five
and six hadley road actually are so
we've we've got clarity about that on
this plan
the right opposite the entrance
basically
right okay so so in answer to your
question council jameson i think um
my usual advice to committee in this
circumstance would be
decide the application you have before
you um but it's within within the realms
of possibility to look to explore a
non-material amendment for this sort of
thing the application layout isn't part
of this application before you this
morning but i'm hearing what you say
yeah
i was i spoke to matthew blackow i think
he's the agent and he was
amenable to looking at some kind of
amendment it's just as i say
unfortunately they're not here so i
can't bring that up with them so
thanks
thank you councilman junction
cancel a beer
hand
thank you i think you've got councillor
hinton before me he's got a number two
on my list but i'm quite happy to go
you go you go next then i'll i'll get
thank you right yeah
a couple of points just to clarify good
morning alex nice to see you um can you
just put up slide number five please
and can you just point out um the hadley
road is the road i assume that come off
from the bypass towards elmsett and i
know where
that is actually um and also the area
where the millies and the airfield even
just give me those directions i can then
be sure i'm in the right place and i'll
come to my second question
yes yes i'll certainly uh try peter um
so slide number five yes please yes
okay so this is slide number five so um
so hadley road is
is here i thought yeah yeah so you come
up there and if you take a left
somewhere up there that takes you down
towards the airfield and where the mill
site was that we gave plymouth missions
some years back yes yes
can you just show me where that road is
okay so that's
up here and then past the site and yeah
and uh
yeah yeah then we went on to the
airfield update yes yes thank you i've
got the area quite clear now the the
second question is
regarding size um because i think this
is one of the things we can sort of
question today uh can i be assured that
this
second or third bedroom is large enough
to be a bedroom and that the garages are
as large as we can possibly get them to
take the cars
um of the future in um because
it's no good building these and calling
them two and three bedroom places when
the room is so small we have managed to
encourage developers to build them
bigger and really i just want your
assurance that you know we've got as
much as we can get and more if possible
thank you
okay um i can assure you on the on the
garages these would be wide enough in
accordance with suffolk parking
standards um so uh
yes uh yeah highways officers are um
uh comfortable with the size of that
yeah
just so i'd interrupt you but i'm well
aware the officers of highways um will
accept the very latest standards but if
you can get more that's better um
because you know it's only
that that new size is the bare minimum
to get a larger car in
but anyway uh let's carry on
yes yeah yeah sorry and um yeah in terms
of the uh the bedrooms um yes i'll just
uh just review the um
the plans if i may and um
get back get back to you in a second
peter if that's okay
yeah that's fine i think mr chairman
through you it's just reassuring the
officers that you know when they're
discussing with these people to point
out that there are counsellors that will
pick these points up so we do want to
try and get the largest rooms and
carriages that we can get thank you
thank you council here
thanks for hitting
thank you mr chairman uh yeah could do
alex if you could put up slide 15 please
slide 15
right whilst
i'm looking at these
one of the few things that we can
actually sort of comment on because we
can't decide anything today under these
unusual rules
is the design of the properties that are
going to be put in there
now
those at the top
uh the other disadvantage of operating
on this remote basis of course is that
the pictures are so damn small you can't
read any of the
legislation the bits and pieces that are
on them the ones at the top the ones
with the sort of windows set into the
gables uh into the into the roof
um
look like village properties
the ones below look like something
that's been stuck onto the outside of a
council estate on an urban area
um isn't it is there where are these
particular properties actually located
on the plan because it's difficult to
see from the plans as well what
properties are where
uh yes i'll try and refer back to the
layout if i may
whilst you're finding that i would just
comment on the on the street lighting
and that is that the mppf did say that
where there was no street lighting in
the surrounding area there was no
necessity to have street lighting on new
developments so the county council
couldn't effectively insist on having
street lighting in uh in rural areas so
that we could have some dark skies
okay um well you know as i said before
that is secured by where conditions so
we would need to uh consider that at the
relevant time
um
okay so uh yeah this uh this gives an
idea of the layouts of a two bedroom uh
properties in in blue uh three bedroom
in uh in yellow and um i've got a street
scene which may be helpful so yes i mean
those properties you referred to council
hidden would be uh
fronting the um the main street scene
with uh with bungalows and the other
dwellings would be set further back if
that's helpful
but they wouldn't be fronting the hadley
road would they they'd be back tied onto
the front to hadley road
um
no i believe that is the elevation you
would uh you would see
from hadley road
i'm glad glad we can clear that up
because otherwise it's a bit confusing
um the second question i had which isn't
covered by the
the reserve matters and everything else
but as everything seems to be
a bit up in the air anyway i'll bring it
up
this site presumably uh is liable for
suds so where is the suds drainage
system going or is that part of the
ongoing flood relief
condition that's being talked about
um yeah so we have
we have four
conditions on the outline referring to
surface water drainage
and um the wording of some is
concurrently with reserve matters i mean
that's hence the
recommendation from the aero planner
manager um
to get that agreed and approved before
we
issue reserve matters um
[Music]
now
this layout that we're looking at today
this has already been considered and
approved um
i mean you know informally as i
understand the site has um good drainage
it's not within a um a surface water
zone and there was no need for a an
attenuation basin um when this was
considered at
outline stage but yet beyond that we
don't have all the technical uh
information but that
is secured by wear condition and we will
need that before we approve
but where does the water drain too you
say it's a well-drained area but it must
be draining to somewhere
it doesn't just sort of vanish
when it uh comes off the building so are
we exacerbating a problem a bit further
downhill for instance because that's
often what happens that a new estate is
built and before you know what
properties some distance away are
suffering from flooding
okay
well uh the site existing uh there are
two
significant drainage dish ditches uh one
of the hadley road frontage one um
along the uh the field boundary to the
south and um
uh yes that's how the site is drained uh
existing and uh yeah we would need to uh
ensure you know flood risk is um
is addressed um by way of those
conditions that's that's all i can
really say i don't have any other
details
so who would be responsible for
maintaining those drainage ditches
because presumably up until now it's
been done by the landowner
um
well yes i mean it would be the
landowner presumably um i don't know if
the area manager can help with that
question please
yes that's always one of the elements
that um the county floods team asked to
be clarified before they would discharge
a condition
so that you'll have the drawing showing
how the thing would work um
uh you know is the flow rate realistic
is it actually going to work as a system
um and then there will be the next
clause of the condition will be how is
it going to be maintained what what's
the um
what's the ongoing stewardship of the
drainage system so that's that's a
matter to be cleared by the discharge of
the conditions
which we have in the decision notice
from the outline permission
on conditions i think is 18 19 20 that
the ones at the end of the um
they're on the recommendation
fine thank you it's just that my own
experience of
working on the emergency planning team
at uh
county is that uh quite often they do
not use joined up thinking on these
things and so it's important that
we try to highlight where there is a
possible weakness yeah it's quite
correct and actually county are i'd say
more than thorough in their
considerations of these matters
counsellor
thank you
councillor osborne you're next
thank you mr chairman um i've got a just
a two-part question really here uh for
alex um hey nice to see you again alex
um
first of all the housing has the suffolk
design guide been
considered on on these properties and
the second part of the question
do these actually blend into the
surrounding built housing areas
as we cannot see the pictures of of of
that housing against the
application thank you
thank you mr german
thank you
uh yes that thank you councillor
um
yeah in terms of the design um i'm i'm
unaware that um the suffolk design guide
has been uh has been considered um
that's that's not been made apparent in
the application um
now in terms of um
[Music]
yeah street scenes and what's going on
around it if i can uh just refer to uh
some of my photographs perhaps might be
helpful um
so uh yeah this is existing uh
street scene frontage with uh with
hadley road
and you might be able to see um the rear
of the dwellings at
garrett's road as well
and then
server at the bottom we have
further dwelling designs uh on hadley
road um
i think that's sort of all i've got in
terms of photographs of existing
character i'm afraid
thank you does that answer your question
ken strasbourg yes yes it does thank you
mr chairman yes it it does in fact um
it's it's just the question that uh from
looking at the pictures that um
alex has provided there it does seem
that the
application does actually blend in with
the with the dormer windows that have
been put into the
roof spaces of uh nearby uh properties
um
what what i would say is that um
can't really
look up i think it i think it's all said
said there that uh
yeah the one point i would make is that
they do look a bit bland um
so
what
you know what the materials that they're
using will that sort of look be it be a
little bit more open than
what you see in the pictures that's the
only other
position i have
thank you mr chairman
thank you
councilman mcgraw
thank you very much chair i wonder if
alex could bring up the overall layout
uh plan uh one of the early slides i
think question relates to the affordable
housing
and its location
it does all rather seem to be
concentrated in the um
i would assume as the northwest corner
assuming the alignment is north-south um
so the overall plan i think shows the
whole site
a bit further back
that's the boy
so uh as i understand it the light blue
and the light yellow are the affordable
houses in this
development is that correct
um they're actually shown in in pink
here
okay i was looking at the overall plan
i was wondering just to try
and i appreciate i could be getting this
wrong so
just could you
indicate on that overall plan the
distribution of the affordable housing i
mean are we achieving the degree of
pepper potting that we require
uh by policy
um
well i mean i i believe so i mean um
i think i think this is the appropriate
plan really um okay and it shows at the
front edge but um yes we've got uh from
north to south with uh
market dwellings in between i would say
that would be okay so it is sufficiently
pepper potted that's fine my opinion is
yes yes thank you very much i appreciate
that it's difficult to tell from again
it's the size of these drawings we could
obviously see better in the chamber
second thing would be then um because
the
the line drawings are in color it's very
difficult to distinguish whether um
the affordable housing and the market
housing are um as it were relatively
indistinguishable
because they're black and white we can't
see from materials and sometimes you can
see
from the color uh depiction
and yes comment on that
um any comments um i i do not have uh
color uh drawings i appreciate that i'm
just saying that appearance is actually
what people judge by and it is a
question of judgment um with people
looking from the outside we don't want
people to be able to distinguish uh to
any great degree which houses are
affordable and which houses are market
okay if i may go back to the uh
elevations of the various dwellings uh a
bit of comparison um okay so we have
elevations of affordable and uh
and here we have the various uh market
dwellings um
yes so
you know i would suggest that you know
the bungalows would be the the same
design as as are the uh as other
terraces so uh indistinguishable
similar external materials being used
yes indeed yes
some would be some will be rendered as
well yes thank you very much cheers no
problem
thank you councilman clinton mclaren
thank you chair
um thank you alex um
and i'm not sure where this question
should go but i'd like it answered
at this stage in the planning process
have has it been agreed who's going to
manage the green spaces
because since 2018 i think as a
council and a planning authority we've
actually changed our direction in the
management of green spaces thank you
uh yes thank you um i believe that would
be a private management company
this has been agreed that's my
understanding okay thank you very much
thank you
councillor jameson i've got you up for a
second time
yeah yeah thanks for that yeah um just
a quick one i think um i noticed there's
a holding objection from ecology is that
still ongoing and um
what is the issue there and the other
thing is looking at the pictures of the
houses
can't see any evidence of pv panels or
or um
parking
charges is that not included on these
developments
um
no indeed um yeah that uh that detail's
not been included in the uh in the
elevations or the um
or the layout and um
having had a look at the um existing
conditions in the outline i don't
believe we have a condition securing uh
sustainability measures um
so i think that's the position we're in
uh councillor jameson
okay and regarding the ecology holding
objection is that resolved or is that
still ongoing
um
this this would chair this would be in
relation to the discharge condition
applications i imagine condition 23
which is biodiversity perhaps values
could check that
um
so that's that's the thing that needs to
be cleared up before we issue the
permission as well so if if we get to
that point alex and it hasn't been
sorted out
that will be have to be added to
phil's considerations after this meeting
um
the
were there any other outstanding points
there
which i think that was the only one
wasn't it i think it was the only one
yeah
okay
um um sorry sorry um you're asking about
um
sustainability issues et cetera if we're
getting that you'd like us to
put in some ev charging etc
you know we can do this
if that's the sort of thing you're
looking for chair
i think so
i think that's a
um mr chairman if i can come in there i
want to follow on from what councillor
jemison said
that um
we're not too late to require some or at
least ask for some electric charging
points and perhaps anything else in that
line and and uh
if we can then can we go down that road
bearing in mind that it must be in the
interest of the developer as well to put
them in at this stage and he's more
likely to be able to sell than better
with with this sort of facility present
so um
can i support councillor jameson and say
that we should ask
what we can get
in um
electric charge and vehicle points put
in
thank you
i think that would be reasonable one
couldn't really argue that's changing
the layout um just having a couple of
dots on my map showing there's an ev
charging point here or there or at
dwellings preferably
so we can take away that and discuss
afterwards
um talking to the developer about
including those things
yep that would be fine mr chairman thank
you thank you
councillor parker you haven't had to go
yet
yeah thank you very much um chair uh i
mean as far as the actual application is
concerned i think it's all fairly sound
actually and
i think my colleagues have covered off
most of the issues but whilst we're
talking about um items that might be
asked for at the risk of being bored to
my members but i hope you'll all support
me 41 units substantial increase
in numbers uh in the village i wonder if
we could also ask for a uh defibrillator
it's a shame the applicant isn't here
but um can we add that to the to the
list of requirements obviously not a
condition not um uh dependent upon um
you know supporting the application or
not but uh nice to have thank you here
here councillor parker i fully agree
with you thank you we can do that we can
do that yes we can ask for that as well
um in discussions afterwards
okay
is there anyone else
yes please mr chairman
um well hang on i've got the chief
planning officer i want to pass a
comment so i'll ask him first then i'll
come to you
councillor hidden
mr israel
thank you chairman yes just just one
point i'm conscious that um we obviously
haven't heard from the parish council
chairman too so
the discussion has ranged quite widely
and i think that uh is an important
point that we perhaps might hear
at some point um
and obviously um
that may well help us pick up some of
the points that have been uh been the
subject of questions but um just just
thought i'd pick that point up german
thank you okay thank you
council hinton johanna
yeah thank you very much mr chairman
just a quick one on two points that have
just been made firstly defibrillators uh
as the local plan is going back to
almost back to square one to be
resubmitted to for examination etc
perhaps it's something we should put in
there as a as a policy that
all new developments or increase in
housing above a certain level um provide
a facility for installation of a
defibrillator
and moving on from there to
electric charging points etc i think
it's important that with new
developments that we
clarify
whether or not they are required and
also encourage the installation of solar
panels
because if we're not careful we end up
with an electricity supply system that
is incapable of allowing all the people
to plug in their cars at the same time
without blowing the whole lot up
so it's important that we keep the
balance of
energy supply along with energy usage
thank you council hinton i'm not too
sure
whether that was a question or whether
it's a statement but um
well as this is an informal meeting and
loft and what we say can be ignored then
uh you can take it either way
chairman if i if i can help on that i
mean the the
joint local plan status i think the
intention is that the inspector will
come back on the
the policies including the development
management policies so
whether there's an opportunity to
include something around defibrillators
is something i can take away for
discussion but i suspect the policies
having been examined there's not a huge
amount of opportunity to change the the
detailed policies of those
because that's what has already been
through examination
and
as regards the point about uh capacity
that that's also something that i think
um would need some careful thought
perhaps you know and certainly in terms
of allocations would be something to
pick up within the part two document
thank you chairman thank you mr to come
back on that point um i think as far as
the local plan is concerned so many of
the supporting documents have been
changed several times without
counsellors having any input into what
was in them they shouldn't be beyond the
wit to be able to put in something about
defibrillators
uh if i can
accept the informality of this mating i
mean chairman the point with with the
process from here with modifying the
local plan
because what you'll see is is a minor
modifications and a main modifications
document that will have to be the
subject of consultation and it would
usually be expected to follow whatever
advice comes back from
the inspector unless we've got very very
good reason
so if the inspector has signed off a
series of policies to do with a b and c
it would be unusual to revisit a b and c
at this point without going back through
the flow of consultation
back through the flow of examination and
and onwards and i suspect there's
probably not much appetite for that but
i'll leave the point there chairman
there is certainly a lot of evidence
based behind it and i accept councillors
interest in the matter okay thank you
i've got no more
hands up that i can see but that doesn't
mean that
is there anyone else with any more
questions
there's no other hands up at the moment
oh good
we can move on
um i will now ask the parish council
representative mr alan newman to speak i
know you've had your hand up and you're
very keen to to to to address this so
perhaps you
if you think you can answer some of the
questions to the officer please do so
thank you very much chair and good
morning committee uh yes i think i can i
don't want to waste my three minutes
honorable i'll i'll extend you well if
you're asking the question i'll give you
another little bit more time to do that
okay fine
a chair we have four points that we want
to make
and i do understand that is a submission
of details but
we want to talk about no street lighting
existing residence parking causing
problems and i hope i'm able to help
with that one um
there's a very deep ditch along the
frontage of the site which we consider
will be a maintenance issue
and there'll be a need for
additional handrails and that sort of
thing because it's very very close to
the new footwear that's going in
and
there is
no detail and this is another important
one of the additional series of passing
bays that were approved
by condition 15 of the original one and
required by that
and
i want to know what a series of passing
bays are and where they'll be you have
not seen any detail of where these
passing days will be so i don't know how
you can approve them right now if i can
come back to some of the questions
um
we did talking about a defibrillator
there is a defibrillator in the village
we have one on the village hall now
whether you
want to ask for a second one on the side
and who's going to maintain it
i don't know but we do have a
defibrillator
um
so if i could come back to the street
lighting issue please
um
we originally asked five years ago that
there'd be no street lighting on hadley
road or indeed on the side um
if i could refer you to our neighborhood
plan oh and by the way the planning
officer said this was the site was
outside the built-up area boundary while
the neighborhood plan has brought it
into the built-up
area boundary so
you need to be aware of that
the lighting issue
in our neighborhood plan on page 13
section 310
we say about the description of elsa
is that roads are not lit other than
hazel wooden church view
no street lights is a decision supported
by the majority of residents and we
therefore enjoy dark skies and clear
view of the heavens which is what we
want to continue with and if i might
just take that a little bit further
you have a condition that you've got to
look to 25 that was as you said
an environmental condition really not
really um on road lighting but uh
no lighting i would suggest is a scheme
that you can approve
the that will get you over your uh
condition uh that you've got to
fulfill
um
i'll be very happy to take any questions
uh i think i think
thank you alan i think what we'll do
first is i'll just get the officers to
comment on on your answer to the
questions early on if you don't mind no
no not a problem
um alex or mark would you like to
yes if i may share i mean
you just remind members that they this
has
it's a difficult thing to say but much
of what we're talking about has
permission already effectively um the
out the layout has permission
we're looking today at
scale and design those are the reserve
matters
we have lapsed into some peripheral
discussions things like ev and
defibrillator which i think are
reasonable but but some things that the
gentleman has mentioned are
parts of conditions which which remain
to be discharged um i think
the passing bays was brought up that's
condition 15. um that or
that decision has been delegated to
us already as officers um
within the context of this isn't a
decision we're making today i'm just
saying that the outline permission um
grants
this authority
permission to
in
coordination with the ohio authority
agree a series of like lay-bys but
doesn't say how many passing days
doesn't say how many
um so so we don't know that we need the
highway authority to talk to us about
what they want
and they have to be pleased by what's
being given to them before they say it's
okay and before the discharge condition
and that's right
they didn't know five years ago
and i don't think they'll know now
right okay yeah fair enough um thank you
in whichever way it's done uh
however many it is that has to be
satisfied before any of the dwellings
are occupied so that
that that acts as a
block to them to the developer not doing
what they shouldn't do
um and and similarly with um
sorry you brought up another issue i
think which i've completely forgotten
about i think it was it about the suds
no it wasn't sorry um
yeah the directions exactly yeah so that
has to be again
county has to be satisfied with what's
being presented
before we can discharge that condition
so
it's it's a tricky one because you're
given a load of plans to look at but
actually all we can really consider
today is um is what things look like you
know effectively how big they are what
the colors are etcetera yeah
the light sorry the lighting was the
other issue that is part of it that is
part of a condition again which remains
to be discharged so we can have a talk
about it and then
we as officers can in discussion with
the whole authority let them know that
some people are worried about there
being too much light pollution but that
matter has already been effectively
delegated to officers to discharge
thank you mark is trying to come in i
think bill
thank you yes um
i think
mark's point is right we we have an
outline permission i mean if you take
the example of
the lighting condition it only has to be
discharged at the point of occupation
that's the wording in the condition
whether that's right or wrong
you know that's not for me to say that's
what the decision is that the developer
can rely on and so
you know i have no ability to ask for
that now i think what mr newman
describes in the way of no lighting no
lighting is a scheme i i agree with him
no lighting is a scheme it's a choice
so i think that involves uh you know
establishing with the county where
they are about to draw a line in
relation to
adoption of roads and footpaths and so
on so there are matters here and i i
don't see the debate uh chairman as
being
prescribed from looking at guidance
around these other matters because
clearly you know the decision is not
going to be issued
today the drainage matter has to be uh
uh
taken to a conclusion
and that will be quite important uh i'd
certainly interested parish but it's
also you know of imports um you know
generally so i i think you know the
guidance that you give here can include
these others other matters and it would
be perfectly reasonable for committee to
you know
talk about things that it thinks you
know should be included in a decision
notice on the reserve matters but as
mark says literally the consideration
today is uh scale and appearance
and some of these other things are swept
up and however unsatisfactory it is it
is
it is the way about line of reserve
matters that some things are swept into
to other other places so
uh the passing base for instance yes it
would be nice to have details of that at
this point i cannot require that and if
you said to me we would like you to do
something about that i'd have to say
well i i can't actually i can't actually
do anything about it because the outline
says it it has a specific timing which
is reasonable thank you jim
thank you i i do understand that and i i
i understand your point entirely
okay
one of the
if i may just go ahead a little bit more
on the residence parking and i know
you'll say well that's not for
consideration today well
it alan i'm i i think i'll really like
that it's not really for the discussion
for today unfortunately i think
um it's unfortunate we haven't got the
agent here but without the agent i i'm i
think we're we're we're going nowhere
with that particular thing
and again i understand my theory is that
we're sleepwalking into uh a road hazard
that that could have been prevented
yeah i accept your comment
right our
members questions for the parish
representative
um
i seen
no hands
is that the case
i've obviously satisfied all of them
thank you very much thank you very much
mr newman thank you i'll see you next
time
actually in fairness chairman could i
could i ask but take the liberty of
asking the parish council chairman a
question on on this this matter of
parking i mean it doesn't appear to me
to from what i read the papers to
feature in the
the outline decision and uh clearly that
that would have been the point at which
it would have been ideal to to
crystallize that
we did
council jameson did
uh mention
the the the applicant is willing to do
something
if we were outside this meeting as a
separate point to explore the
possibility of a non-material amendment
to the layout which is the outline
permissions yes yes that's something
presumably the parish council would be
willing in principle to engage as a
discussion and and kind of knows the
issues sufficient to be able to describe
it as that absolutely
thank you
thank you thank you thank you
thank you
councillor busby
you're a late comer but can i have your
question please
better later than never
alan yeah you've said you've got this
site in your neighborhood planned yes is
there anything in your neighborhood plan
that is not
i feel like complied with in this
application
well i don't think so uh we we haven't
mentioned
uh
no i don't think there is not in the
neighborhood plan um other than the
lighting which as i've said
we would like dark skies and that is in
the plan
thank you
thank you
there are no other questions
thank you mr newman can i ask you to
close your microphone and camera and
while we move on with our next
speaker
thank you um
i know this isn't informal meetings but
council jameson as ward member
do you wish to address the planning
committee or review
already
um
well most of the points have been
covered in terms of the appearance
um i
looking at the drawings we've got i've
got no real issues it would be nice to
read color drawing colors so you can
actually see
um obviously we can't do anything about
that but that would be nice about actual
color pictures
and it would be nice i know this was
decided back um
four or five years ago
but to vet some kind of um
sustainability report and
on the um
you know
it's become more important since this
was agreed and it would be nice to have
that included perhaps in this
application if we could have done
but um no it's it's not part of this
application so it can't be um
yeah
looking at the houses they look fine to
me
with drawings we've got
um yeah but other than that and other
than what's already mentioned i've got
no real comments at this stage
thank you council jameson
um
we are open to you to be questioned um
i can't see anything
no so we have no more public speakers i
will now
invite a discussion
um
[Music]
councillor parker would you like to kick
off
thank you chairman uh it's just a point
of interest really as much as anything
uh if we got any um information on on
what the the still liability is um on
this development because it occurs to me
that with a neighborhood plan uh there's
a special dividend here for the um for
the parish as well which might go some
way to offset um some of the concerns
but um yeah just be interested if we
know what that what that is just purely
out of interest
one of the offices
can you help
uh i i think i can probably speak for
colleagues in saying no we don't
actually have a a figure that we could
give you in relation to the sell
contribution but you quite rightly
you've identified the key factors in
relation to this that that parish does
have a made neighborhood plan
um which is
i'm as far as i can take that that
aspect yeah okay
thank you
right
um
mr russell you wanted to comment please
yes thank you the issue of the ecology
was mentioned a little earlier it's been
doing a little bit of research so
basically that condition hasn't been
discharged yet but it doesn't need to be
discharged yet uh that just needs to be
discharged prior to commencement of
development
okay so we'll make sure that happens but
it need not uh affect today's debate
thank you
councillor mcgraw
yes man crawl um sorry um
chair it's just a comment but i was
wondering
it appears to me that although we're
only providing a steer to the chief
planning officer on the uh the matter to
be discussed and determined or to be
determined by him later i think it could
be said quite reasonably that we've also
provided a steer in how the remaining
discharge of conditions from the outline
section
might have been
covered in other words when officers are
in discussion about the discharge of
those conditions i'd hope that the
points raised today all of which seemed
very very good to me the
all the matters dark skies drainage all
the rest of it i'd hope that that has
given officers a clear enough and and
suffolk highways a clear enough steer
about what it is that members are hoping
to see would that be a reasonable
reading of the situation
i think we need to ask the two
so mark or phil
okay
uh yeah i'm i'm making notes as we go
and trying to crystallize what i i am
hearing here um and my sense is that
this is a useful steer across a range of
things not just the reserve matters uh
chairman
thank you
mother
right councillor busby
thank you chair just a kind of general
question really well it's taken five
years to get to the stage where we are
and it doesn't look like we're anywhere
near completing this application
is there a reason for the delay and have
we got an anticipated start date
i suspect that's a decision for for the
agent who's not with us but whether
mark has any information
no no we don't
we don't know when um i think sometimes
sometimes the reserve matters do come in
quite late on and um it's better that
they come in a bit early but in this
case it is where it is so we don't know
what date they're wanting to start
okay
okay
councillor parker
yeah thank you um well i'm just going to
sort of
uh head in here straight away um chair
and say because we are in uh uncharted
territory here is all something new to
um to us at the planning committee but i
would just like to say that if we were
in a formal committee meeting at this
point i would probably be minded to uh
to make a proposal to support this
application we're not but i would just
say that um given everything that's been
discussed and all the points that have
been covered by my colleagues um if you
require a steer from uh from me uh it
would be that i would support this
application thank you
thank you lee counter red
um yes thank you chair and i too would
support that thank you
thank you
alistair councillor mccraw confirms i
would steer that way as well in approval
any more comments
nope
then
i'll move back to the cheap planet oh
claire sorry
thank you chad i just wanted to um
just in terms of transparency counselor
owen has just declared that she's got a
non-pecuniary interest in the item so
just so that everybody knows
i believe it was this item i don't
know it was the go start one
it's an example right okay thank you
thank you i just want to make sure that
was clear thank you thank you
so the next one made it clear um
so well
um who's got his hand up sorry
no no one
i'll go back to the chief planning
officer then and
see whether he has
enough to confirm the proposal
thank you chairman um uh uh
based on the discussion that i've heard
i think um
it seems to me that um
the uh the recommendation to uh look
into
suds
is appropriate that there are a number
of other matters that need to be uh
looked into
including the potential to impose an
ev charging condition on any decision
um the question of uh lighting and
passing bays i think are the matters to
explore with the applicant together with
that question of a non-material
amendment and i will take those
uh away with the intention
of uh
of doing that
because i think that's important to give
the parish and the developer a clear
understanding over what's intended to
come forward as the detail here because
obviously this is only
scale and appearance
and you know i'm mindful that against
that there are various policies in the
neighborhood plan which all seek to
achieve that in terms of design and
space standards
i
i think the question that
uh the chairman of the parish council
raised in relation to the ditch
maintenance and another matters are
probably matters of
uh private relationship will be swept up
into the um
matter of the
sustainable drainage proposal under a
condition and the question of means of
enclosure is already the subject of a
condition elsewhere but i've
made a note of these issues
uh and
in essence chairman i'm minded to accept
the uh the recommendation in the report
to deal with these other issues uh as a
as a follow-on to uh this meeting
chairman okay
thank you phil
if that's the case then i that brings
this item to a conclusion
thanks for the guidance jim
okay um
moving on do people want a quick break
before the next item begins
any consensus
or shall we go straight on
thank you chairman thank you alan bye
carry on chair carry on
you carry him
yes cancer of buzzfeed don't want a
coffee
no no he doesn't
thank you peter
i just went to the queen now let's move
let's move on um council jameson you you
confirm that you may have to go
before this item finishes
um
well it depends how long it takes i need
to go 11 really so
so we might realize that okay
um
so moving on it's um
and and this is the one where
uh councillor owen has pecuniary a
non-pecuniary interest was it cancer
owen
sorry yeah yeah non-paclunia i'll just
help out there occasionally
okay thank you
fine
that's all registered um
can i ask um
the next one is um unit 6 south suffolk
business center uh can i ask the case
officer linda bacon to introduce the
application
linda all yours
thank you mr chairman and good morning
members
hopefully
you've got something on your screens
before you now to view
um in which case i'll
i'll continue
okay so
um i
haven't heard from anybody so i'm
assuming that's still there um and we're
set to go
so um this is an application for the
change of use of amenity land at the
south suffolk business center and it's
to provide
parking for a community transport
operator
the application is submitted by an
officer of the council on behalf of the
operator of the site and that's go start
the site is also owned by baber district
council hence its consideration by
members today
this
is an aerial image it shows the location
of the site
in its context and to the south
you've got newton road
to the west is sudbury
sudbury cemetery
north of the site is the former delphi
factory
and immediately to the east
of the site are some residential
properties the south suffolk business
center
is this building located here
and immediately
to the south of that is the council
depot
this identifies the site in red it
occupies a small corner of immunity land
at the
south suffolk business centre
and until recently it was an overgrown
and underused area of land
it's adjacent to the main car park
for the business center which is here
and access to it is
just to the north at this point and the
council depot adjoins to the south
relevant constraints are that the site
is in the built-up area boundary it's
within a designated general employment
area
and is included in an archaeological
area also
so the application seeks full planning
permission to use the land as an
extended parking area
for a community transport service based
in the business centre that sits
adjacent
the submitted plan
shown here does need correcting though
it's been incorrectly
rotated to show that vehicles access
from the south of the site
at this point whereas the intention is
in fact for vehicles to enter
from the west from the main car park to
the the business center
an amended plan has been requested and
is still expected
turning to some site photos this is the
existing access into the business center
from alexandra road
the parking area is shown adjacent
this is the business centre
itself as it presents to alexandra road
this shows the site in use for parking
by the community transport service
it's a graveled surface that's been
laid behind a sporadic hedging along the
frontage
the palisade fencing to the rear is to
remain and beyond the site
these are residential dwellings
this is a view from within the existing
parking area at the business center
this is a closer view of the same
so beyond the palisade fencing at the
rear there's a further area of amenity
land that separates
residential properties um on the left
side
from the council depot on the right side
this um shows part of the business
center car park um in the foreground
with the council depot beyond the
fencing um to the rear
this shows part of the site frontage
onto alexandra road
the brick wall to the left side encloses
the garden land to the adjacent dwelling
and this shows the brick wall as it
turns the corner
so your officer's assessment is that
this is a modest extension to an
existing car park that's within a
general employment area that will be
used by a community transport service
and as no immunity issues to warrant
refusal have been i've identified
it's recommended that once the submitted
plan has been corrected by the applicant
the chief planning officer grants
planning permission subject to no new
issues arising from the outstanding
consultation with the local highway
authority
and subject to the conditions as shown
thank you chairman
thank you very much linda
um
moving on
are there any questions for the officer
oh
hi
i see another one oh counselor yes go on
yes i was just going to wonder there's
no lighting but previously go start have
lost some of their um catalytic
converters so i wondered if there may
need to be a bit of lighting that was
all
in there would you comment whether
that's part of the application or not
lighting isn't part of the application
and indeed one of the suggested
conditions is that there would be no
external lighting without our prior
approval so that would be subject to a
condition if the applicants
so wish to install it
thank you
councillor
just a quick point mr chairman
presumably then this is effectively a
retrospective application because
they're already using the area for that
purpose
indeed the works have
commenced during the life of the
application
thank you
no
any more questions
no there's no more hands-on
i
that's the easy but i can see that when
there's no hands up
it's when there's hundreds of them i'm
in trouble
um moving on we have no
um
no applicant no no more public speakers
and the board member is council osborne
who
you wish to say anything that's perhaps
with the time to say adrian
uh
thank you mr chairman yes uh just a a
brief
outline of of of go start
um
go start have been searching for an
appropriate site uh where they can
safely store their vehicles
uh for some time
as they as uh our councillors has
already alluded to they've experienced
damage to
their vehicles
um the site presents
an ideal opportunity and it's not a huge
area and will enable the go start to
continue uh to provide the valuable
service for our communities it
particularly the uh elderly who are um
taken uh on on several trips to the
hospital over the over the uh times and
i believe um
i believe it's it's a community asset
that is really wanted i mean transport
is a is of a premium and and uh
go start have been for years uh uh
obtaining grants to be able to continue
with their with their uh community um
support um
transport so
i agree with uh
the officer linda linda for for the
area that she's covered and i have no
problem in supporting this it's a very
good
um
community asset and particularly in
regards to the transport thank you mr
chairman
thank you councillor osborne
are there any questions to council
osborne
no
i will now open it up to
a discussion has anyone any comments to
make
other than to suggest that we recommend
the chief planning officer
um
oh sorry yes
we hand over the chief planning officer
sorry
sorry i wasn't i wasn't actually
intending to step in at this point well
there's nobody's opening the discussion
i think um okay
i have one council has just decided to
ask questions so shall we take that
first before you
please
yeah just a quick one
as you say it's open for the discussion
now i think this is a relatively minor
sort of application and if it wasn't for
the fact that it had been submitted by a
an officer of the council uh would
probably have been done on delegated
powers so i think that uh
it's something that uh there are no
major problems with i'm not sure it'll
solve their problem in terms of
catalytic converters as councillors has
mentioned but uh
i can't see any problem with it
it may encourage them to go electric
cancer
ashley mccraw
is every reason to support this this
isn't just in general comment and steer
and no reason not to and i would thought
i would have thought that was fairly
obvious for all members
thank you
and then more questions we'll move to
the chief planning officer
so thank you chairman uh on on that
basis i'm minded to accept the
recommendation detailed in the offices
report and to proceed with the decision
um
uh under delegation uh as authorised
chairman
thank you phil
right
that's the case
on my notes here i'm now told i must now
formally close the meeting but as it's
an informal meeting i just wonder what
formerly closing means but um
almost like a throwaway that uh they'll
be alright if they went electric with
their buses
you might have seen the the item on
breakfast television this morning where
a firm of ex grand prix drive mechanics
etc have developed an electric
double-decker bus up near norwich
somewhere
which has got extended range but they
didn't actually tell us what the range
was but obviously as this bus service
property
service is quite a tight area it's
probably ideal for operating with
electric buses
okay
thank you council hits
i'm gonna have to
formally close the meeting thank you
everyone for your attendance um we've
got through it i'm not too sure
you